hey guys how's it going today's my
birthday well actually to clarify
today's the 19th tomorrow's my birthday
the 20th and I'm posting this on the
21st so yesterday was my birthday today
isn't even my birthday what am I saying
this is crazy
we're having so I didn't want to have a
birthday party I was like no party no
nothing and then somehow I think it
turned into one I didn't mean to she
said I do not want to have a party I'm
like okay I'll get a normal sized cake
and now you're like oh these people are
coming over for a party and we're stuck
with a normal sized cake normally we eat
cakes for like 50 people is beautiful
and it's the centerpiece of the party
and now I'm gonna look like a bad sister
it's okay the centerpiece of the party
is the switch show your switch joy I
show your switch here Josh switch we
still have a bunch of other uh party
people coming some are coming to brunch
and then some are just coming later to
place which we plan on playing Zelda all
day long and I'm so which cookie these
are so awesome are they gluten free
Jenna got you a gluten-free cupcake I
have to eat my real food first and then
I can have my cookie right
oh my god wow it's so bright our
separate ruin how are you how are you
Teresa Francesco said this is for Maddie
and me dog him oh my
[Music]
that was that's creep Susie you're not
oh my goodness that's the craziest thing
I've ever seen Maddie do you like it
he's also scared cause he recently ran
into the screen oh sorry
look at that it looks so good thank you
I still can't believe these oh this is
insane
how do they get them to your door I
don't know even how like this is
possible if there's so many yeah yeah
that is so cute
it can absolutely be the same I can't
make it but there's some sort of
surprise coming this is so so silly so
silly you're gonna fix your by it I do
okay could you take a photo for me
little Matty is terrified it's okay babe
hey give kisses I fixed this little
crate for him speaking to have some
little privacy
[Music]
we just don't Francesca Howell this
party is happening but she didn't
realize she thought this was like a
multiplayer game yeah like you're all
gonna go stay in a room and play
individually but just all to get like in
the same room but separate we all have
our own game going on do you think
that's hard how do you interact with
each other and then Lamar beat the game
I think he's the only one that beat the
game I haven't wanted to beat the game
because then I have nothing to look
forward to in my life yeah but that's
like the main thing that you work for is
beating ganon and I'm not ready we also
have a ton of amiibo girl I haven't
thought myself I already started and you
I feel like it's cheating and it should
be a band cool we'll have fun I'm gonna
be over here living in my armor it's so
good I've been playing this game without
just just this manna from heaven yeah
it's like so many items I have so much
meat now it's like you could go sell
this you get so many like
whatever you can so if you stack five
pieces of the raw meat cook it that's
120 rupees that you can sell at the
place yeah because it's like so many
things I want to buy like I want to buy
that house have you got the house yeah I
got it the right way and like some
clothes but yeah you have it three
thousand rupees where to get three
thousand rupees
oh here's a little track there's a mini
game that you can play where you can
hunt deer and boar you're supposed to
kill it for the game but you can collect
the meat and then you'll collect the
meat and you'll get coins or you could
do both this is the most raging party
ever
hi how are you so good switch party how
are you doing your switch I love my
switch and I love Zelda and I know it's
the best I love it so much and she just
got the barbarian helmet but you got
that did you buy the whole thing so now
we're gonna go do the other labyrinth
probably that's great that's great
but before that we gotta have some cake
are we gonna have that cake oh I forgot
about that okay so guys if you haven't
donated to my charity yet I'll put a
link in the description but this is my
charity water cake that I made fries
check this out really good I wanted to
do like a charity water well themed cake
I thought this would be really a good
idea oh crap
the water was so heavy it just fell
through do you think you can take the
water out now or no will we got a backup
cake okay let's take it out and see what
happened you're gonna go back together
on crack we put that back in I just
ruins everything we don't have to be
just gonna light a fire she's nice over
here on the we've got switch cookies so
we're partying really really hard this
which party is really great Oh Travel
chocolate runs you're not too foreign I
got like like an hour
no five hours okay you know this is how
it starts
once you hit 20 then you're ready to
roll already like after 20 it's it's all
uphill but man I feel like the first ten
hours was just like man I'm not doing
anything it's kind of a lot of grass
collecting a lot apples hey you can get
some those meatballs back there then
Jenna's over there fighting with Matty
with another amigo bring him over here
so I can see what mommy
[Music]
we're flying amiibo precious okay so
Ashley made these incredible cookies oh
my we're really good oh boy we we're
trying grinding today that's what we're
doing it eating cake and pizza and
getting wild so I gotta go I got I got a
I'm going to my fourth divine beast
right now it's happening now now alright
this is the end of the vlog is midnight
we've basically played pretty much all
day I mean we definitely took some
breaks for napping every time I'd comes
over to play he ends up falling asleep
light switch oh my god I'm so tired
so yesterday it was my actual birthday
March 20th and also Lindsey Stirling's
hold my heart music video came out and
I'm so excited because I may or may not
have a cameo here's a little bit of
behind-the-scenes footage
you got your caste and just steam some
right these are my friends hold on us
friends beautiful beautiful is why
because I'm left-handed you know oh oh
you are I mean no whatever so
[Laughter]
[Music]
make sure you guys go check out the
video I'm so excited to be a part of it
and Lindsay is absolutely incredible so
go take a peek and I will see you guys
later
I gotta go to bed my eyes hurt from from
watching too much of the TV did you have
fun playing Zelda that was real good
yeah so good it's good stuff so good um
JB's in the bathroom so he says bye and
Matty's eatin his his late night
midnight dinner he was supposed to eat
this like it's seven hours ago this your
midnight dinner thank you for all the
birthday wishes and go check out
Lindsey's music video and I will see you
guys later
Oh oh wow oh shoot not then it's done
but like and you're done mrs. villiage
not gone Oh make it work